you have helped turn me on to several
progressive congressional candidates
around the country it has kind of blown
my mind
how little in the way of national
resources is going to
many down ballot candidates around the
country and districts that
maybe they're not a slam dunk for
democrats but they should at least be
competitive
uh and uh and it feels like you and i
are some of the only people supporting
at least some of these
these candidates where you and i differ
though is that you
have an attitude of wow it really blows
my mind
i have an attitude of how [ __ ] dare
they because there's a reason for what
you just said and that is the corporate
democratic machinery
that does as much to purge uh
progressive voices on a congressional
level on a senatorial level
as they do on a presidential level just
like they did with the presidential race
this time and they did with the
presidential race
last time in the democratic primaries
and so
the progressive candidates and i agree
with you there's some great people
many of whom did not make it through
their primaries many some of whom did
but they are not given the support they
often are not the people who already
have their own
resources they're not lawyers and
business people necessarily
they might be scientists they might be
teachers or whatever
and the the money from the democratic
party is given to those
that are what they believe are the
candidates um
uh who are more likely to win this is
why our friend john hickenlooper who i
certainly he was a lovely man but this
is why we have john who is didn't even
want to run
we have him rather than the
extraordinary andrew romanoff in
colorado
it's why we had sarah gideon uh rather
than uh
uh then betsy sweet it's why we have um
amy mcgrath instead of breyer or booker
so
it's there's something dark there you
know and
i believe it needs to be named and i
believe that it's the wrong call for the
democratic party
i don't think that's where the people of
the united states are and it's certainly
not
where the majority of democrats are the
majority of people in this country
andrew want medicare for all
when you look at things such as
cancellation of college loan debt
when you look at things like universal
health care when you look at things like
uh free college tuition at state
colleges and universities
these are very popular ideas
so why are we running a presidential
campaign where apparently
there's more effort to to lure
republicans than there is to please so
many democrats particularly progressive
democrats
i don't understand it i don't understand
why there were more young people
at the at the convention speaking i
don't know why there's not more reaching
out
i don't know why the burden is only on
them to
fall in line some of whom i'm very
frustrated with as well
don't get me wrong because i do believe
that the most important thing is to
remove the fascists from the white house
but i also see on the part of the
democratic party a pushing away
of people who are voters or at the very
least potential voters
and that concerns me very much it didn't
work in 16
and if they're not careful it won't work
in 2020
i'm with you on the frustration and one
of the things that i saw
work out in the primaries is that if you
were progressive running against an
incumbent there were very very few
organizations or figures who will help
you
and that's true even if let's say you
were
let's say you're a member of congress
and you're like a died in the world
progressive it's very very unseemly for
you to
endorse uh someone who's primary one of
your current colleagues
like that there there are some real
rules against that in terms of decorum
and so if you are let's call it a
progressive democrat running against an
incumbent
like they're like it it staggered me
how short the list is of folks who might
conceivably get behind you because
democratic establishment is not going to
get behind you unless the incumbent
is mired in scandal yeah
it's more than about incumbency it's
about more than incumbency
it's about a viewpoint of the corporate
centrist democrat
it's not just the incumbency and when it
comes to the incumbency issue
there have been some real wins look at
cory bush she was able to defeat
a a longtime incumbent look at jamal
bowman who was able to defeat the
longtime uh
incumbent and of course that whole trend
was started with aoc
who defeated the long-term incumbent um
so bush in particular the race is on
yeah corey bush in particular because it
was in in missouri
uh and her opponent uh i think his name
was lacey clay
um like hadn't
screwed up in like any any uh mammoth
fashion i mean i was excited for cory's
victory
um but in missouri like you can see it
more clearly in a place like aoc's
district or jamal bowman's district
um but missouri was an earthquake uh the
the problem
is that it is so remarkable frankly
that you're like no way like an
incumbent lost to their
primary challenger i looked this up
marianne because you know i love math
uh the incumbent reelection rate is 94
percent
so if you are going to to defeat an
incumbent you're you're literally at
least statistically looking at you know
like a sub 10
chance uh of victory and now having seen
the dynamics play on these races i
understand
that more clearly because no one wants
to help you
you know except for frankly someone like
you someone like me sometimes
like a very very small handful of
organizations because
people are loath to antagonize the
incumbent
uh and getting behind the upstart seems
like a bad move quote unquote
politically
even if you know that that person's in
better
step with the values of that district or
with the american people
and at this point it's almost it's not
quite irrelevant but it's almost
irrelevant if the majority of the people
are for it
well exactly and it's and it's totally
absurd and naive for us to even pretend
that the political parties are seeing as
their first job facilitating the voices
of the people
they do more to manipulate and to
dictate
than to facilitate look at something
like what's happening right now with
black lives matter
black lives matter is the largest social
movement that has ever existed in the
united states
and how much of a difference has it made
in any legislation whatsoever
the voices of the people this is what's
wrong the democracy
itself is broken and as far as the
incumbency is concerned
it's a club and the club has many ways
of protecting itself and multi
layers of resistance to any penetration
into any change
now i'm a hundred 100
sure that we need to actually fix the
machinery of democracy
in order for it to represent the will of
the people anymore
okay so in part because of what you just
described about cash relief
to me it's obscene that you don't have
every single democrat on board with a
version of cash relief instead of the
50 or so that currently are on board
thank you
it shouldn't it include shouldn't it
include joe biden
that's my point to you that's my point
so what we've done is we've actually
tried to put pressure on
individual members of congress say why
aren't you for this bill why aren't you
for this bill
and we've managed to get a few more not
as not as many as i'd want
what are the reasons or excuses that
people democrats have given you for why
they're not
well i i'm like you in that i think many
of these members of congress are just
going to do whatever they think is in
their
political self-interest so if you say to
me why are they not on this bill
it's because they think it's better for
their political self-interest not to be
on the bill
so then you say well how do you make it
so that it's in your political
self-interest to be on the bill and one
one way to do it for me is for me to say
hey look the yang gang would like you a
lot more if you are in this bill oh
and if you're not on this bill then
maybe we will support this person who's
going to challenge you
and so so those are the kinds of
conversations that we have actually
been having and they haven't been as
successful as
we'd like because people right now do
not see
that it's in their political
self-interest to do what the american
people see is obvious
because right now 75 percent of us think
that there should be cash relief during
the pandemic
so once again why is it that you don't
just do what everyone knows is common
sense and the right thing to do
i don't know why you think it would make
you unpopular to say
to people we're sending you money so you
can survive
exactly like how is this not a home run
for you
and the same with medicare for all
though the same with so many of these
issues
so to me i mean there are so many
problems
stacked in here uh the main problem is
that if you are
a member of congress with a 94 success
rate
at being re-elected you just become this
creature
of uh of washington
um and you have these consultants around
you whose careers depend upon
your continued membership in congress
and so if someone comes and says hey
like do this big thing
um that will to at least some people in
your district make you seem
um like quote unquote like radical or
something about those lines
they have like five people who are
essentially like their breaks on any
kind of move like that being like no no
no
like uh like don't don't embrace this
thing they're they're like they're
barnacles on them
uh and the goal has to be that we
actually make it so that
they see that the water is fine and that
if they go this direction it will help
them
see that's where you and i are that's
where you and i separate a little bit
it's called corruption total
and complete corruption it's not only
what you said about their constituents
it's also about the leadership of the
party
when nancy says we're doing this no
we're not doing that and even the ones
who would agree with us and are playing
the long game so they go along
that's exactly what i mean now
until that's called uh for what it is
and when you talk about all of the
operatives yeah they're they're circus
performers it's
it's uh that's why i call it a campaign
industrial complex
it's thicker darker and deeper than
i feel we just we're describing in this
conversation
and it has nothing to do with a
government of buying for the people
it's a government of by and for the
corporate interests
that are then spending all the money in
order to
make sure some people win and some other
people lose it's not just the uh the the
consultants it's what the consultants
are telling them
and so if you know i don't know why
in congress unlike in every other
profession we all have to make ethical
decisions
you've you've been in business you've
you have a career where i'm sure you
were called upon
to make an ethical decision i might make
more money if i make the unethical
decision
but i'm a human being who wants to
respect myself so i'm going to make the
ethical decision i don't know why
we give congress people a pass oh well
he or she can't vote the right way
because they'd lose their job
lose your seat have some
have some conscience lose your seat if
it means if doing the right thing means
you lose your seat
lose your seat and we need to say that
and we need to call them on that and we
need to get over our delusion
that if we just vote blue
it'll all be fixed i mean if you look at
the bailout if you look at the
this bailout which is so horrifying the
as i said
i call it the drop dead bailout it's
corporate bailout as opposed to people
bailout right and i know you feel
strongly about this
yeah it's it's really the same template
as the bailout in 2008.
the bailout in 2008 was corporations
versus people
and they just took the same template and
they went on steroids
the whole system is that corrupt and yet
the system mitigates against people
calling it out on its corruption and
that and that's why it's going to be an
awakening of the american people
who vote uh in such in in such
massive numbers for people who are
calling it and what we have are so many
people who recognize the corruption
but who feel that their way of resisting
is by not voting
yeah understandable you have to give
people something to vote for
that's the thing direct cash relief
would be something people would vote for
medicare for all is only people would
vote for college
you know cancellation of college loans
do you know how many people would show
up to vote for a presidential candidate
who said i'm going to make your life
easier
and i'm sorry it's not enough to just
say oh
yield is all of america how about some
policies is going to make your life
easier
it's not enough to just say we're not
donald trump
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you